the eyes of the football world are
focused on Qatar and so is its history
the world of football is a special
six-month exhibition featuring balls and
jerseys from the 19th century all the
way through to the present day we have
six Galleries and one activation
zone for the kids and to discover the
talent it is a unique but the galleries
itself today we are showcasing more than
1210 objects and believe it or not we
have a ball from 1888 we have Muhammad
Ali's gloves when he retain his title in
1978 against George Foreman in Kinshasa
Zaire
there are several artifacts connecting
the past to the present
this was the first trophy awarded to the
winner of the World Cup Tournament back
in 1930. and this the trophy we have
come to know so well in more modern
times there's more than a Century's
worth of football memorabilia on display
here and of course everybody will have
their own personal favorite but perhaps
the Highlight is this the very Jersey
worn by Diego Maradona in 1986 when he
scored the infamous hand of guard goal
against England
there are also miniature models of each
of the World Cup host stadiums
and a special tribute to host nation
cutter the first Middle Eastern country
to host the competition the people that
they will arrive they will the minute
that they the the airplane touch down
you know and Doha until they leave back
they will have an enjoyable stay on
Qatar they will test the hospitality of
Qatar the world of football exhibition
is part of the wider 321 Qatar Olympic
and sports museum but no doubt in 2022
this is the center of attraction at the
venue Peter's limit Al Jazeera Doha